Відсторонення від роботи й обмеження поїздок "Укрзалізницею" для невакцинованих,
ввічливі прохання показати сертифікат у кав'ярнях викликає спротив українців.
Відсоток вакцинованих в Україні хоч і зростає, але доволі повільно.
У Європі певні обмеження діють ще з літа, тож там, де найперше на них наважилися, зараз найвищі показники з вакцинації.
Австрія, судячи з усього, стане першою країною у Європі, в якій вакцинація від ковіду стане обов'язковою.
Нещодавно канцлер Австрії Александер Шалленберґ оголосив, що країна спочатку йде на суворий локдаун,
а з 1 лютого наступного року всім австрійцям доведеться вакцинуватися обов'язково.
Наразі відсоток тих, хто повністю вакцинувався, в Австрії складає трохи менше 66 відсотків.
Це один із найнижчих показників у Європі.
Я сподіваюся, що всі розуміють, що достатнє підвищення рівня вакцинації дозволить вийти
з цього зачарованого кола дискусій про наступні локдауни.
Нам не потрібна п'ята хвиля. Ми не хочемо ані шостої, ані сьомої хвилі поширення коронавірусу.
Хоча таке рішення викликало хвилю протестів у Відні, австрійське керівництво не збирається відмовлятися від своїх намірів.
Зараз у країні діють одні із найбільш суворих обмежень:
на вулиці не дозволено з'являтися невакцинованим особам старше 12 років без крайньої потреби.
Хіба що у магазин за продуктами чи до лікаря.
З якого віку щеплення стане обов'язковим і що буде з тими, хто свідомо відмовиться від вакцини, поки що достеменно невідомо.
У решті країн Європи рішення, вакцинуватися чи ні, поки кожен може вирішити сам, але відмова значно ускладнює життя.
Приміром, в Італії до роботи допускаються лише ті працівники, які мають "грін пас" -
сертифікат про повний курс вакцинації, виписку про недавнє одужання від ковіду або свіжий негативний тест на коронавірус.
І, звісно, без "грін пасу" випити кави або сходити в театр у Римі неможливо.
Хоча за законом обов'язково вакцинованими мають бути лише освітяни і медики.
Завдяки цим заходам Італія досягла позначки у 73 % вакцинованих і порівняно спокійно переносить четверту хвилю.
Зелені паспорти вже стали нормою для французів.
Люди показують їх з екранів своїх телефонів на входах у бари, кінотеатри, музеї, у поїздах та аеропортах.
Кожну суботу в Парижі відбуваються акції протесту незгідних з правилами контролю,
але попри це відсоток французів, які вже отримали дві дози захисту проти коронавірусу, високий - 70.
У країні, яка першою у Європі запровадила ковідні перепустки ще навесні, вже вакцинувалося 76 відсотків населення.
На початку вересня Данія скасувала всі карантинні перевірки і обмеження.
Але, на жаль, хвороба нікуди не ділася, тож Данія розпочала вакцинацію третьою - бустерною - дозою вакцини
і повертається до практики ковід-паспортів.
У Німеччині щеплення від ковіду - добровільне.
При цьому влада закликає до бустерної вакцинації, стверджуючи, що ще одне додаткове щеплення
через шість місяців після попереднього "має стати правилом, а не винятком".
До кінця зими кожен у Німеччині, може це трохи цинічно звучатиме, провакцинується, перехворіє або помре.
Поки що у Німеччині діє правило трьох П - провакцинувався, перехворів, протестувався.
Тобто щоб відвідувати публічні місця треба бути повністю щепленим,
мати довідку про одужання протягом останніх пів року або мати негативний ковід-тест.
Утім, у регіонах з високим рівнем зараження вже діє правило двох П -
лише провакциновані і ті, хто перехворіли.
Крім того, повернули можливість раз на тиждень безкоштовно тестуватися на коронавірус.
Раніше, скасувавши безкоштовні тести, влада хотіла спонукати людей до щеплення,
сподіваючись, що тих, хто обере безоплатну вакцину буде більше, ніж тих, хто готовий платити за тест.
Утім, через рекордне зростання нових заражень вирішили відновити безкоштовні швидкі тести.
Повний курс вакцинації у Німеччині пройшли близько 68 відсотків населення.
Через драматичну ситуацію з пандемією і порівняно низькою квотою щеплених - 58%, цього тижня почали діяти нові правила для невакцинованих у Чехії.
Ті, хто не отримав дві дози щеплення проти ковіду, більше не зможуть показувати результати негативних тестів на ковід
перед тим, як заходити у бари, ресторани, перукарні чи музеї.
У ці місця можна буде зайти лише тим, хто недавно перехворів або повністю вакцинувався.
Такі правила змусили чехів вийти на вулицю в Празі із гаслами "Свобода".
Окрім сертифікатів щеплення від ковіду - документів, які відкривають майже усі двері поза домом,
деякі країни запроваджують обов'язкову вакцинацію для тих, хто працює з людьми з груп ризику.
Так, до роботи в будинки літніх людей і лікарні не допускають невакцинованих працівників в Австралії, Великобританії, Франції, Греції.
А в Новій Зеландії анонсували обов'язкову вакцинацію для всіх вчителів, медиків та асистентів людей з інвалідністю.